[Music]
suggest some details about how I mark my
scores quick and hold the editing
options come up and I use this
highlighter option so right now it's
yellow but I could change the saturation
transparency and I keep it around 1/2
transparency so I actually see the notes
underneath the color same with
saturation so I just take a color
usually red it's easy because I can
always find it if you just scroll to the
left so then I was do min and say this
is the voice I'm wanting to mark I just
go ahead and drag that so in terms of
color options are not really consistent
about what colors I use for what but I
try to be consistent with in one piece
so as you can see I use different colors
for the different lines and that's just
to separate them visually I wouldn't use
different shades of red for example
because it's hard to see for rhythm I
like to use a lighter shade of some kind
of color and I draw lines vertically
also here these red lines it just
reminds me of hearing that connection
between those two notes a lot of times I
mark in letters here the G here is DB
and I also use this kind of light orange
pen for fingering but it depends
sometimes I use blue sometimes days
black red I also use those lines to
separate the score in sections that I'm
going to be working on also I use these
highlighters to just group certain notes
and passages that that I use to spot
where I am or I use as anchor points
various different things I also use the
highlighter for phrase marks and also
even if it's on a few inter lines other
lines
just easier to follow so these are have
divisions I think that pretty much
covers it any other marking that I would
do in a regular score I just do with
different types of pens or highlighters